STEVE: ALL RIGHT, MEANWHILE TO
OUR OTHER TOP STORY TODAY, DHS
SECRETARY MAYORKAS SAYS HE’S
GOING TO TRAVEL TO OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER WHERE YOU SEE THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE STREAMING ACROSS THE
ADMINISTRATION RAMPS UP
DEPORTATION AND NOW THEY’RE
SENDING PEOPLE BACK TO HAITI.
BRIAN:  THIS COMES AS AGENTS ON
THE GROUND GRAPPLE WITH MORE
THAN 14,000 MIGRANTS WHICH AS
THEY ENTER THE COUNTRY WILL
BE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS CAMPED
UNDER A BRIDGE IN DEL RIO TEXAS.
AINSLEY: THAT’S WHERE LAWRENCE
JONES JOINS US, GOOD MORNING.
REPORTER: GOOD MORNING, FAMILY.
THE BORDER IS STILL AT CRISIS.
NO SIGN OF THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
HE’S STILL VACATIONING.
THE BORDERS CZAR KAMALA HARRIS
IS FLIPPING COINS AT FOOTBALL
GAMES AND SHE’S NOT HERE DEALING
WITH WHAT’S HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND.
THE ONLY WAY I CAN DESCRIBE THIS
AND I DID A TOUR YESTERDAY,
AT GROUND ZERO, WHERE ALL OF
THIS IS PLAYING OUT, IS IT’S NOT
JUST A CRISIS BUT IT WAS A
PREVENTABLE CRISIS AND I CAN
ONLY TELL YOU THIS.
THE CARTEL IS WINNING.
IN THIS BATTLE, THEY ARE STILL
HAVING PEOPLE GO ACROSS, THE
TEXAS DPS SHUTDOWN PART OF
THE BORDER AND THEY FIND ANOTHER
WAY TO GET  ACROSS.
RIGHT HERE BEHIND ME IS THE
LEGAL PORT OF ENTRY.
YOU SEE A LOT OF COMMERCE COMING
THAT WAY A LOT OF PEOPLE COMING
HERE TO WORK THAT’S NOT WHAT’S
SHUTDOWN.
YOU CAN NOT GO IN OR  COME OUT
BECAUSE THE SITUATION IS THAT
DIRE.
WE’RE STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
GOING TO DO.
RIGHT NOW PANIC IS HERE.
YOU SEE A LOT OF THE  DPS COMING
THROUGH, A LOT OF BORDER PATROL
COMING THROUGH, REINFORCEMENTS,
BECAUSE THEY ARE AFRAID THAT THE
FOLKS THAT ARE THERE AND
THESE ARE HAITIAN IMMIGRANTS BUT
THEY’VE BEEN IN SOUTH AMERICA
FOR 10 AND 15 YEARS JUST WAITING
FOR THEIR CHANCE.
THEY’RE AFRAID THEY HAVE GOTTEN
WORD THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE
DEPORTED.
A LOT OF THESE FOLKS WILL BE
DEPORTED BECAUSE OF OUR CURRENT
IMMIGRATION LAW, AND THEY DON’T
KNOW WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO DO
SO THAT’S WHY YOU SEE THIS
INBOUND TRAFFIC AND
MORE ASSISTANCE HEADING YOUR WAY
STEVE: LAWRENCE JONES LIVE IN
DEL RIO WHERE THEY SUPPOSEDLY
STOPPED THE FLOW OF MIGRANTS
ALTHOUGH IT DOESN’T LOOK LIKE IT
, THANK YOU.
AINSLEY: THANK YOU, LAWRENCE
PEOPLE ARE SAYING IT’S HARD TO
FIND WATER AND FOOD FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS, THERE’S
GARBAGE EVERYWHERE, PEOPLE ARE
SLEEPING IN THE DIRT.
BRIAN:  6,000 WERE THERE BY
WEDNESDAY, EXCUSE ME, 9,000 WERE
THERE BY WEDNESDAY, ANOTHER
6,000 OVER THE WEEKEND, WE’RE
OVER 14,000 AND MOST OF THEM
FROM HAITI ORIGINALLY BUT MOST
CAME FROM COUNTRIES IN BETWEEN
CHILE AND BRAZIL.
THEY WERE THERE AND THEY SAID
HEY, I HEARD IT’S A GREAT TIME
TO GO TO AMERICA.
JOE BIDEN’S PRESIDENT.
AND THEY DID.
AINSLEY: BORDER PATROL
DISCOVERED 49 UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS INSIDE A TRACTOR
TRAILER AND THEY HAD THE CANINE
UNIT AND THE DOGS SMELLED
SOMETHING WAS SUSPICIOUS AND
THEY OPENED UP THE TRACTOR
TRAILER THERE WERE 49
INDIVIDUALS IN THERE FROM BRAZIL
, ECUADOR, GUATEMALA,
MEXICO, AND PERU.
STEVE: SO MANY FROM HAITI
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT GAVE THE
HAITIANS A TEMPORARY